so thank you for being here if you have
questions about Cobra computers or the
hackers from the early nineties in
Romania and just feel free to ask but I
should start by giving this small
present I was talking about so do you
remember what was the name of that
computer virus that displayed a fractal
on the screen a was built in the early
90s by someone in Switzerland
you know what the name of the virus was
to cure it thank you thank you so much
this is some brandy plump original plum
brandy from Romania awesome um do you
have an have question was I boring
or not no yeah please you mentioned
there I mean we were talking about some
like dean of faculty amateur yeah yeah
being very happy about this fun hacking
and you mentioned blocking from
computers yeah so you could couldn't
access the computer anything else
anything else happening there anything
so how does this work were they just
blocked over they talked to well did
they talk to the seaside mins when a
student wanted to use one of the
computers from the lab he had to talk to
one of the sysadmin
so the sysadmin were also allowed to
block the students for a week too and
maybe more this is why they there are
still frictions between the two parties
at the moment so but the the only one
that was cut out completely from
using the university's computers was
Larry so you have as a student if you
did something bad you'd have to go there
and sort of negotiate along your block
or in Eastern Europe we don't have
specific rules and this is both good and
bad it's bad because if you don't have
procedures then things often don't go as
expected but this lack of procedures
also gives room to negotiate the deals
so yeah
they had they had a talk each time thank
you
I have a question I had a chance years
ago I think 12 years ago also to visit
to miss fava they had some kind of PDP 9
that also seemed to be it was an
official university computer but it also
seemed to be not a real original PDP 9
but something self made like a clone
somehow was there some kind of official
strategy of accepting of cloning and
building somehow legal that also made it
easier for the guys I think all the many
of the products that were built in
Romania and maybe another Eastern
European countries were clones of
Western products but I'm not sure if
this this was a strategy for
the four for hacking I don't know that
but yeah it first it was a way of using
other people's R&D and building products
that were cheaper and easier to make
because you wouldn't spend a lot of time
into thinking how we should make them
sell it was it was a bit easier like the
Chinese did up until a few years ago
is this is this such this is a cheap
computer okay this was sold in Romania
in the early 90s there are three
different types of chip chip one two and
three this is a three and it was made by
electronica Factory in Bucharest and he
it's quite similar to the cobra
computers I talked to before it was made
in a factory and many computers like
this ones were marketed as gaming
devices and they were displayed next to
a TV set so that people would buy them
both together we we brought several
games we have manic miner we have chaos
Frogger
if you want to play that game with the
frog that tries to cross the street and
there were also some games Romanians
cloned if it was a clone game after the
Chucky egg game and it was called the
chicken in Romania it was made by some
engineers working in a small town in
Romania this is why it was called gonna
from brayla brayla being the name of
that town and they wrote on several
funny messages if you play the game and
one was this game was made by engineers
from eg Braila outside business hours so
if their boss came to them and say what
are you doing so this game was said to
be developed outside business hours I
still want to write a story about this
game I've managed to find one of the
developers but maybe in the future
what's interesting is that this also had
there were also games that came on audio
cassette tapes and these entered Romania
likely with the help of pilots from
people working for airline companies
from the state Aaron company that
brought them or there were official
leaders of the Communist Party who hid
them inside diplomatic suitcases and
people used to copy this game this games
in there also there was also a TV show
in Romania it was a radio also a radio
show in Serbia that did pretty much the
same they aired computer games so you
would basically record the the person
working for the radio or the TV would
say now you should start play and record
what's going to happen next and they
will basically record the sound and just
then they would load the game into their
machines
was there any like specific shift in how
these people have been interviewing
operated after 1989 or did they just
kind of keep going with what they were
doing was there any like major shift and
like how they were allowed to operate or
what they were doing or why they cared
about what they were doing
yeah they mostly did what they did out
of the fact that they wanted to learn
more and wanted to be creative at that
time in the early 90s and even the late
90s there were gangs of carders in
Romania people who would find I know
credit cards that belonged to people in
the u.s. mainly and they used those
cards to buy goods probably you've heard
about hacker ville that's a town in
Romania the FBI had an office there it
was the Carter's town so but Carter's
weren't welcome in IDEO double one
computer lab this computer lab was only
for people who wanted to learn and they
somehow excluded people who wanted to
steal money this was not a kindergarten
playground it was the big league but
things changed in Romania after hard
legislation addressing computer hacking
was pushed it is one of the harshest I
would say in Europe so yeah they don't
operate the same today can you tell us
more about how students gained access to
the foreign foreign service they hacked
and how like software security worked
back then in general ah yes
many of the students back then in
Romania in the early nineties developed
their tools from scratch they would
spend hours in the lab challenging each
other and learning from each other
information was their currency there so
they basically developed their tools by
themselves
Larry worked for two years at his worm
trying to make it stout here and there
did the same vampy I think that the same
so the fact that they had total freedom
allowed them to learn more than people
who had certain restrictions so yeah
they've they were also hunting
vulnerabilities
Larry created the database of
vulnerabilities there that were both
known vulnerabilities and
vulnerabilities that he and his
colleagues were able to find and there
the worm relied on these vulnerabilities
and when he found the servers server he
would try different scenarios
so in case in case you haven't said that
you might have said it there's change in
legislation when did that happen
yeah in the early 2000 2002 into the or
2003 yeah okay so it's it's still in
place
was it a response to a specific event
that happened I know no I think it was a
lot of people complained about Romanian
hackers and not really quick hackers
Romanian people who steal money using
credit cards so yeah and like is there
been any like high-profile cases where
people have been I don't know what the
actual you know penalty is or fine or
jail or something
there wasn't one high-profile cases no
but there were several smaller cases
there were hackers who served time
because in the US and in Romania for
what they did I think that one of the
most known hackers Romanian hacker
hackers is Gucci fell a few years ago it
was this story about Gucci for to
hacking the u.s. elections so this was
actually Russian but posing as a
Romanian hacker Gucci fur is now the
Romanian Gucci fur is now jailed
somewhere in western Romania I had the
opportunity to write letters to him and
he replied and told me about life he was
a taxi driver and he managed to break
into a couple of email accounts and find
critical information but it wasn't a
very brilliant hack he just tried
different passwords and some of them
worked
it was like entry-level hacking compared
to what the IDEO double one guys did
I've also tried to find if CERN or the
Pentagon have logs from that time
apparently they don't so I think they
are safe I think they're pretty okay if
we don't have we don't have questions
anymore I think we could also you could
DM me at any time or email me if you
want to learn more about Romanian
hackers or Romanian computer scientists
in general I will try to answer the
question and maybe direct to you to
better skilled people so thank you so
much thank you